notre PR2 est un stade de conception
détaillé à ce stade donc voilà dans un
je ne sais pas quel parallèle je peux
prendre pour pour pour pour représenter
ce qu'est la conception
détaillée j'ai tendance à prendre la
cuisine IKEA comme comme comme
comparable je pense dans tout ce qui est
les dans ce qui tout ce qui définit les
objets essentiel de du réacteur on est à
80 90 % à ce stade euh simplement voilà
dans la cuisine IKEA vous n'avez fini de
monter la cuisine que quand vous avez
tout y compris les petites vis et voilà
voilà et donc c'est voilà donc nous
entrons dans la
phase de conception y compris de de de
du détail du schéma d'exécution voilà
c'est parce que même en voilà dans un
schéma électrique on dit voilà vous avez
le schéma de conception si vous avez le
schéma d'exécution on est dans la phase
dans laquelle on commence à définir les
schémas d'exécution et ça va répondre en
partie à votre question sur le prix
parce que le prix d'un d'un objet
industriel comme celui-ci c'est quoi
c'est l'objet qu'on construit le temps
qu'on y met et sa structure de
financement et donc il nous faut encore
beaucoup travailler un peu travailler
sur l'objet et c'est pour ça qu'on y
travaille avec l'ensemble de la filière
industriel beaucoup travailler sur le
temps et travailler sur la structure de
financement et c'est l'ensemble des
trois qui nous déterminera Infiné à
forceor sur les objets récurrents c'est
pour ça nous devons nous focaliser
stratégiquement sur
la performance que nous atteignons en
objet récurrent pour faire en sorte que
cet objet récurrent il soit dans la zone
de
performance qui est qui est souhaité à
cet horizon de temps est-ce que je suis
capable de vous dire quelle sera la zone
de performance de l'électricité en 2040
ou en
2050 si je l'étais peut-être que je
ferai pas ce métier c'est possible mais
je pense que nous devons tout faire pour
être capable d'être au rendez-vous et
pour y être il nous faut travailler sur
ces trois paramètres et c'est l'objet de
la phase d'optimisation dans laquelle
nous entrons